Well, good morning church.
It's great to see you today.
Maybe you're new to our church
or maybe you were here last week
at Easter for the first time.
We'd love to meet you and get to know you a little bit.
There's a new here area out in the lobby.
Just go say hello at some point.
When you're ready, happy to meet you and include you in that
and try to get you connected here.
But it is an exciting time to be here as well
because we are starting a new sermon series.
As you saw on the bumper video, the title is realigned
and we'll be looking at what a life transformed
by Christ actually looks like.
And the prevailing image you saw there is that
of a plumb line
or plumb, bob, depending on
where you grew up in the country.
Now, a a plumb line is simply a pointed weight
that is attached to a string suspended from a chord
like you can see it here.
And, and through the consistent pull of gravity,
it establishes a vertical reference.
It's how people since at least ancient Egypt have,
have set a vertical standard.
They've made sure walls and towers and castles
and other structures were vertical.
It was the standard for accuracy.
Even God used as an illustration in the Book of Amos.
He uses the plumb line to tell Amos how far
God's people had fallen from following him.
Now, I think we can get this right.
It's, it's understood that we can, uh, grasp that idea.
But let's, let's then think of an alternate way to try
to find the vertical reference.
I read one author talk about this.
Imagine if the builder of a tower
anchored the line to the ground first
and then lifted the other end to
what he perceived was a point directly above it.
Like imagine if he set the vertical alignment
from the ground instead of to the ground,
like even the most skillful builder
with the best eye would get it wrong, right?
So you could be four degrees off
and you end up with another leaning tower of pizza, right?
Uh, or, or maybe listen, maybe he's really, really good.
He's really skilled and so he gets it just two degrees off.
But he certainly would not be able to set
a perfect vertical.
It would only take a small error at the bottom
to lead to severe misalignment at the top.
But here's, here's what that author described.
See, every other religion,
every other system
of morality starts at the bottom.
It creates standards from the minds of people
and then it puts those forward as what you should try
to obey in some way to try to earn God's love and,
and try to earn his favor.
You're reaching upward to try to gain the favor of God,
but it's always off.
Only the Christian faith begins at the top.
See, we are made right with God first,
and then we obey his law
as it is suspended from above.
See, it's not about somehow working our way to God,
it's responding to his salvation
in his power by realigning ourselves back
to the perfect standard.
See, here's what the world does.
The world sets its own standard,
but Jesus shows us what vertical looks like.
And see that's what this series in Roman 12,
Romans 12 is gonna show us.
It's gonna show us what that standard is
and then how we are to realign our lives back to it.
How the Lord realigns us back to standard vertical,
perfect center
and why that's good for us, why
that's good for God's glory,
but also why that's good for the world around us,
how this will all play out.
So let's pray and ask God to help us towards that.
Lord, we do ask you in light of your word and
and what this picture will portray.
And we pray that as Romans 12 becomes
what we study over the next couple months, that Lord,
you would just infuse it deeply into us,
that we would realize how far off alignment we are.
But how you are the perfect one pulling us back
to that standard.
As hard as that can be to think about the possibility
of doing that, God, you empower us.
And I, I pray, God, you show us that today,
even working today to change our hearts in Jesus' name.
Amen. And so if you're not already there with me, uh, turn
to Romans 12 in God's word,
Romans chapter 12 in the New Testament.
We're gonna be there for a couple months.
So go ahead and put a bookmark there.
We'll just be there every week
until school starts again in August.
But um, Romans 12, new Testament, all the gospels
and then Acts, and then Romans, Romans 12.
Now, before we get there though, I think
I wanna show you part
of why we looked at Romans six last week at Easter.
It wasn't just because it was a good study for Easter,
it actually sets us up for today
and for this series as well.
And so just like last week, believer, listen, you
and I, we must recall who we are
I guess we go into today as we go into this whole series.
We've gotta remember who you are
because here's the temptation.
I know it's coming as we go through Romans 12.
The temptation will be to make this some kind
of moral effort in order to make God happy.
That you're trying to figure out a way
to earn God's love some way somehow by being perfect,
being aligned to his standard.
And it's, it's all about your effort.
Listen, we can't forget
who we are as we go into this.
What God in his love has already given us, not
by virtue of how well we do with this or not,
and we saw it last week.
First, if you are in Christ, you are dead to sin.
Again, identity, this is who you are.
Christian, if you're in Christ since he died
to sin, you are dead to sin.
If you're in him, you are dead to sin as well.
It brought death. His death brought sin to nothing.
And so if you're in him, if you identified with him
by faith, you are dead to sin as well.
That means you are not enslaved to sin any longer.
You don't have to let it have control in your life anymore.
I know it's hard to consider that,
but it's true that Jesus died to sin.
If you're in Jesus, you are dead to sin.
It doesn't have control anymore
because you've also been brought to life.
Like not only are you dead to sin, you're also alive to God.
Now, once in your sin you were dead
to God in a sense, right?
Eternally. But now you're alive.
You're alive to God in Christ Jesus physically
resurrected on the third day,
one day we will physically be resurrected as well.
But even today you are alive
to God spiritually just as Jesus.
It says in Romans six, lived his life to God.
You are able to live your life to God in your
life spiritually.
It also means you don't have any fear of death anymore.
You don't have fear of eternal consequences anymore
because you're identified with Jesus resurrection
that brought sin and death to nothing.
Well, here's what Paul then does with Romans 12.
This is like the hinge phrase, these two
verses we're studying today.
This is the hinge of the entire book.
All that's in the background, right?
Chapters one through 11 describe in full form the dead
to sin, alive to God, nature of the Christian, all
that God did to make that happen, he did it.
Romans one through 11, that's what he pictures.
Well watch the first few words of verse one in Romans 12.
Now it says, brothers, he is meaning just everybody
listening, brothers and sisters.
So I appeal to you,
therefore by the mercies of God.
Now anytime you see that word,
therefore you gotta ask what's the therefore,
therefore, right?
And so it's a linking word.
It connects you to something he just said.
And so what it's connecting you to is all of
what I just described.
Romans one through 11.
He's described the gospel, what it does in your life,
what it does to to, to save people
who are sinners, enemies of God.
He does all of that. Romans one through 11, therefore,
but notice what else he does.
He also summarizes all of chapter one through 11
with this phrase by the mercies of God.
Notice how he said it.
Therefore, I appeal to you by the mercies of God.
So he's just taken by the mercies of God
that the mercies of God.
He said all of that I just told you in 11 chapters.
Here's what I mean by that.
The mercies of God, all that is the mercies of God.
You are all of that by God's mercies.
Not because you earned it, not because you deserved it.
You're an enemy of God. You're dead in your sin.
He gave you all of that by his mercy.
He's not given us what we deserve.
Instead, he graciously gave us what we don't deserve.
We deserve to be separated from God. We deserved his wrath.
And yet he didn't.
Instead, what he did is he died for our sin.
Now, as you, you need
to know this about the way a, a pastor works.
Like each week I'm discovering things along the way as well.
And I asked the question of this, I, I said,
why is it plural mercies of God?
Like I thought God is merciful. Is there just one mer?
Like are there more than one type?
I I just had to ask the question, why is it plural?
I think because we're gonna need mercy upon mercy,
upon mercy, upon mercy, the rest of our lives, day by day
by day, mercy upon mercy.
It's mercies right by the mercies of God
that covers all your sin, past, present, future.
It's mercies that we will need.
But this again, it's clear here, right?
This is who you are, Christian.
You are dead to sin.
You are alive to God. And you know why?
All because a merciful God loved you enough
to save you and redeem you from all of that.
Like that's love, mercy.
The mercies of God makes you all of that.
You don't deserve it. You couldn't earn it.
You could never get there yourself.
And yet he said, okay, I got you. And he made you new.
So that's what he says.
I appeal to you by the mercies of God.
Don't forget the mercies of God.
Well then the question comes, what do we do with that?
Like what should our response be to that truth of
who we are by the mercies of God?
What should be our response to that?
What he says next, give who you are.
He says, remember who you are.
Let me tell you, this is all who you are.
Recall that mercy upon mercy to make you this.
What do you do with that? You give who you are,
you give look at verse one, all of it.
Now I appeal to you.
Therefore, by the mercies of God, that's his case
because of the mercies of God to present your bodies
as a living sacrifice, holy
and acceptable to God, which is your spiritual worship.
So again, the call to action
is based on the mercies of God.
I appeal to you by because of the mercies of God.
That's why you should should what?
That's why you should do what he says it.
That's why you should worship God by giving yourself to him
because of God's mercy for you.
Here's what you do. You give yourself completely
to the Lord worshiping him as you do so.
And listen, we could spend hours on this one verse.
There's so much here,
but just notice a couple things about it.
Notice he says that true worship
is far more than just singing songs.
That's what we have to talk about, right?
We're going to worship like we're just singing.
It's far more than that. It's far more than just attending a
church service once a week.
He says, true worship here is is much more than that.
It is presenting yourself
as a living sacrifice.
It brings up the idea of the Old Testament sacrifices
where they would have this, this offering
of a spotless animal
or the for the first fruits of a harvest
and they would bring it to God
and it was acceptable if it was done based
on God's standards.
If it was said, here's how it needs to be, here's
how it needs to be given all of that, that's
what God's word says you are to be, that you are
to do Christian.
It says you are the sacrifice now, not that lamb, not
that bird, not the grain.
You are the sacrifice that you spiritually crawl up on
that altar and die.
Now, we know it's not literal when he says die,
because what does he say it is?
It is a living sacrifice.
Living sacrifice. But hear me still a sacrifice.
And I don't draw the line anywhere
and say, okay, God, you've got me up until this point.
But beyond that, I'm gonna take myself back.
That's not how sacrifice works.
It's all in this is
death to self.
He says, a spiritual act of worship
where you step off the throne of your life
and you allow God the king to reign in your life.
That's the sacrifice.
Second Corinthians five 15 says it, he died.
Jesus died that those
who live us might no longer live for themselves,
but for him who for their sake died and was raised
and he didn't die.
So that you and I could live for our own pleasures,
our own comforts, our own pursuits of life.
He died so that he could make us alive.
And in so doing, doing, we live for him now.
Like all of it, not just 60% of it, all of it.
And did you notice how he described the sacrifice?
He said, it is a holy and acceptable sacrifice.
Now all over scripture, we are called to be holy.
God says, be holy as I'm holy.
So there is a pursuit of that.
We'll get to that a little bit later, but,
but again, I'm discovering things along the way.
I don't think I fully put this together.
I read that from my western lens.
I read this in this idea like I've got to be a holy
and acceptable sacrifice to God.
That's not the way the context works here.
The context says you already are a holy
and acceptable sacrifice to God.
Not because you've earned it, not
because you should have done it
and you did it and you proved yourself.
No, by the mercies of God,
you already are holy.
You already are acceptable to God. Watch this.
Jesus in Hebrews 13, suffered outside the gate in order
to sanctify the people through his own blood.
That word sanctify means to make holy.
He has done it already.
And then Romans five, one says that we are justified
by faith in Christ.
That word justified is a legal word.
That means you're made acceptable.
You're made right with the judge. What does that sell?
What does that say? It says, you already are holy.
You already are acceptable to God.
You are a holy and acceptable sacrifice to God.
So hear this since you already are,
since you know that God will receive you as his offering,
you don't have to wonder anymore.
You don't have to wonder like, well, am I good enough?
Am I holy enough? Is God gonna accept me? He already has.
And so since you know he's gonna receive you as an offering
in front of your life to say, God, I'm all yours.
I'm all in. That's why you say it,
because I already am.
I can dedicate myself to God knowing
he's already accepted me.
He will receive me as I dedicate myself to him.
He's gonna receive it because it's his work in my place.
And so you put all this together,
That Means the Christian life
is not a dreary obligation
or just a set of rules that we have to follow.
When you look at it through the lenses,
we're looking at it for the last 20 minutes.
And you just look at this
and say, this is what we're talking about.
The Christian life is about.
It is a joyful response
to God's kindness in saving you.
Man, I, I remember growing up
and all I felt was like, man, it's just a bunch of rules.
I don't get to have as much fun as everybody else
'cause they get to do the sin stuff and I don't have to.
Like, it's just this rule following. That's what it is.
It's dreary, it's obligation after obligation.
No, if we think about it like this,
like God saved me from all that God's mercy is great and new
and that what a gift.
That stirs joy, a joyful response
to God's kindness in saving me,
a sinner, an enemy.
And he never had to. He could have completely existed
without doing anything to save us.
And yet he loved me enough to do what he did.
Like this is a reply of gratitude.
This is an overwhelmed, saturated with grateful heart.
Kind of love for God because he loved us first.
But that's true worship, isn't it? Just imagine.
Imagine if you walked in here every Sunday,
if you walked into your workplace on Tuesday,
if you walked into your school classroom, whatever it is,
and your, your whole perspective
is just, you're stunned by the fact
that God brought you from death to life.
How would you think differently?
How would you speak differently?
How would you sing differently?
Give, serve, gen, all of that. How would you do that?
So di you would say, God, I'm all yours.
Your will be done in my life today. I had nothing.
I brought nothing to the table. You gave me everything.
So all I can give you is everything.
I'm not perfect at that. None of us in this room are.
But just imagine the more we awaken to that reality
of the mercies of God and what he does through that.
See, that's this whole transformed life we're gonna talk
about over the next few months.
It's just a response.
It's a spiritual act of worship where you offer yourself
to God a living sacrifice.
But here's what I know will happen if you do that.
As you do that, as I do that, what happens is that your life
actually begins to change.
You recall who you are, both
that you were a sinner and God saved you.
You recall who he's made you to be,
and then you are then giving yourself to him.
As you do that, you begin to then apply who you are
as you live out life in this world.
Like you remember who you are.
And so you say, okay, God, I'm giving all that I am to you.
And then it, it shows up as you apply it in your life.
Thankfully, verse two here in Romans 12 gives us what
that looks like, what that spiritual worship day
by day would look like in our lives.
Look at verse two. It says, do not be conformed
to this world, but be transformed by the renewal
of your mind.
That by testing you may discern what is the will of God,
what is good and acceptable and perfect
because we're dead to sin, alive
to God by the mercies of God.
Because of that, this is now what we can do.
This verse is what we can do.
And notice he says a couple things.
First is that we don't have to conform to the world anymore
because of the mercies of God,
because who he's made us to be.
Because we've given ourselves to the Lord who don't have
to conform to the world anymore.
Like that's the verse. Do not be conformed to this world.
Now that's a passive translation there.
And that's probably the way you've heard this.
If you've heard it described
before, don't let the world squeeze you into its
mold, into its form.
Nothing wrong with that. That's true. It's right.
We shouldn't. But when you actually look at the
original language of this, it could actually be in
the middle voice.
The Greek language has active, passive, and middle.
Middle is where you actually do the action to yourself.
And so the idea here is
that this could actually be
translated a little bit differently.
This might have some more power for us.
Do not conform yourself to this world.
See how that's different? There's a
responsibility there to us, right?
Don't conform yourself to this world.
Now that word conform actually has a, a root
of fashion like that.
You see some way of dressing
and you try to match it even though it's not who you are.
Now, we've all seen this, right? Somebody sees a fashion
trend pop up on social media and so they try to copy it
and it doesn't really match who they actually are, right?
I'm not saying anything about anyone else,
but uh, like you just try something
because they think it might work,
but it's not actually inside you, right?
And so it doesn't, doesn't work.
And we all look at that and think,
that's really sad that that person's trying this.
But they don't. They don't have any concept of that
because it's not inside you.
And so we have to think about this with the idea
of what this author wants translated
Romans 12, two to list to be.
Listen to this. Stop assuming an outward
expression, which is patterned
after this world, an expression which does not come from,
nor is it representative of what you are in your inner being
as a regenerated child of God.
Did you hear that? In other words, it's you are dead to sin.
You are alive to God, all by the mercies of God.
You've been made new.
So stop acting as if you're not. That's what that says.
You are child of God. You've been made new.
You're a new creation, not of the old way.
You're dead to sin. You're alive to God.
So stop living like the world does.
We are to live distinctly Christian lives in opposition
to the way the world that's unbelieving
and doesn't have the transformation.
It's different. So
we are not to morph
into this whatever bottom up standard
that the world puts forward and says, this is important.
This is what we're supposed to be about.
This is what's good and right. No, we're not to do that.
Romans 12, two says, we are to be transformed
by the renewal of your mind.
Now, this one is passive.
This is God transforming you and me into his image.
It says, be transformed.
Do not conform yourself to the world. Be transformed.
It, it's different.
Now, the word here in the original
language is metamorphosis.
Now, if you've taken any sense
of science in school at all, right?
You understand this, that it's the concept
of one thing turning into another thing like a butterfly
coming from a caterpillar, right?
They're, they're kind of the same,
but they're totally different, right?
So the transformation that God brings is passive.
He's doing the work on us.
But notice in the text, Romans 12, two, there's an active
sense when it talks about renewing your mind.
See, here's the reality.
Every one of us, we are immersed
24 7 in this
river called the world.
And it influences the way we think, the way we act.
And the only way, way to change that is
to hop out of the river,
to stop letting our minds drift
to worldly fashion trends.
And instead, we've got to renew our minds for the purpose.
God has them to be renewed.
Like we can't think like the way of the world thinks.
We have to have new minds have to think differently. Okay?
So how do we do that? How do we jump outta that river?
How do we get outta that stream of thinking?
Well, two Corinthians three 18 gives
us some encouragement.
Says we all with unveiled face, behold the glory of the Lord
are being transformed.
Same word into the same image from one degree
of glory to another.
And this comes from the Lord who is the spirit.
You wanna know how we are transformed?
We behold the glory of the Lord Jesus Christ.
How do we behold the glory of Jesus?
We can't see him in this world.
He's not walking around like he was 2000 years ago.
How do we do that? Well, thankfully two Timothy three, 16
and 17 says, all scriptures breathed out by God
and profitable for teaching, for reproof, for correction,
and for training in righteousness that the man
of God may be complete equipped for every good work.
Here's how we jump outta the river and we land
and we, we sit in this renewal of our minds.
It's by gazing upon Jesus in His word.
That's how he transforms us.
So we're trained, ready, equipped.
We understand things differently.
We're corrected when we're wrong. It's through His word.
God transforms us into the image of Christ through His word
as we treasure Christ here.
That's why this is so important, not just
to have a quiet time every day,
so you're seeing who Jesus is.
So you're seeing who that perfect vertical standard is.
You learn about him, you grow in him,
and then he changes you in that.
That's what then plays out to realize
our form in this world.
Don't conform yourself to this world.
Be transformed by the renewal of your mind.
And as that plays out, you then realize your form.
In this world, we think differently like Christ,
we realize a new form.
The goal here is not just to think differently as much
as good as that is, as helpful as that is,
it's not just to think differently.
The end goal is living it out.
James one says, not just be hearers
of the word, but be doers of it.
It's not just up here theoretical. You are to live out.
I am to live out who I am in him.
Now, just think about it. Actually live it,
not just correct a few bad habits.
So I'm not as bad as a jerk down the street,
but to actually live a whole new life,
like complete everything different about me.
That's what this says, by the way.
That's one of the definitions of the word realize.
We don't use it that often in that way.
We think about discovering
or awakening to something like, I realize
that that person was in the movie.
I didn't see it before.
Like the word realize actually has a definition
where you realize a profit on a sale
to bring into actual existence
and possession to render it tangible.
In other words, you realize something, you apply it,
it shows up in your life,
it becomes realized in day-to-day living.
So that's what I mean here, church, listen,
as we get into this series, that's what I mean.
If you are a believer, you have been given
a new form in Christ.
Second Corinthians five, if anyone's in Christ,
he's a new creation.
The old is gone, the new has come. You have a new form.
So live it out
in the world, live it out.
You don't have to go get away from every.